I've been a little faster loose with
some annotation at the beginning and how
I set up the questions so this is
probably a better way to do it let your
partner not be such and also you know
don't just jump yeah I mean you can you
might get lucky maybe the questions
about weren't that much and if you jump
straight here they weren't paying you
for you know not making logic clear
however maybe not so what why is a five
equal to zero because he wants ability
to pay the loan after five years alright
so now I can actually start to form an
equation based on all of this
information what is a five
what's a five if my borrowed amount is B
it's not 50 grand anymore right
I've got B at the front and he has the
one from five years so it gets five lots
of interest on it right then you get
your next college corresponds to the
repayments okay I keep on trying to
indicate to you what each B signifies so
that you're not just doing like mindless
arithmetic or algebra okay so you know
what each part actually means it's
really employment it's 10 grand and then
we had our series over here for all the
repayments he made which I think was
awesome this is audience at 1.15 power 5
minus 1 all divided by 1 5 and that's
equal to 0 okay cuz he wants to finish
the loan so by now you've got 70
questions and for Johnny you probably
getting the idea that it's always really
the same kind of question it's the same
kind of setup it's just a different
target that you're after
you just go rearrange these questions
not hard I just have to get all my
things in the right places
okay so I'm off to be put this over the
other side there's my denominator I'm
gonna have to divide by this as well
just to get beyond its own right okay so
what value do you end up with being
careful with your brackets and that kind
of thing someone got it it's like 33
yep okay from which you can make your
conclusion therefore he can borrow and
then you do your approximation now just
before we young leave off Johnny I just
come back to your table one last time
and let some slop this inning yeah I
wonder if you find this result as um as
intriguing as I did because if you come
back to the very first question we asked
right which is after five years of
making these repayments what kind of a
debt would he make in his life and we
noticed it wasn't a very big one
he hardly got halfway how much he
actually got read over the low there's
about 17 grand bit under 17 grand but
then when we rephrase the question say
what if we borrow a different amount it
turns out he can borrowed drastically
more than that almost twice as much as
the 17-game he paid off in the first
place it has that work these questions
are almost the same he's got the same
compounding rate interest rate
repayments and time was the difference
or the difference are you probably
noticed it's just how much it borrows
right just by virtue of borrowing a
larger amount at the beginning that's
what makes him pay off so little and
actually this should make sense to us to
get this think about this price it's
question to a feed more on either crust
enormous for this time but if you
borrowed sixty six thousand six hundred
sixty-six tone and seventy cents sir-sir
coincidence it says if you work out what
happens every year fifteen percent
interest right the fifteen percent
interest turns out to be happy rounded
of ten thousand dollars and one cent
right so he makes his his repayment of
ten thousand dollars every year but
because of how much he's board at the
beginning his repayments never make any
dent in the in alone in fact I was just
gonna get bigger and bigger forever okay
so what's the moral of story if you can
help it don't borrow large amounts of
okay borrow less because then you'll
actually be able to repay them by the
end even though 33 grams and 50 grand
you might think ah such a difference
between like Corolla and a Mazda 6 or so
like that right but it makes a big
difference in the long run okay so you
can see the numbers why it works because
of this series